okay all right here we are Richard
rejoin us oh great our pharmaceutical
companies to blame for the increase
prescription drug overdoses sure let's
blame them
partly yeah I mean they're in it for the
money right I mean that's exactly but
that's what people don't yeah they're in
it to save no they're innocent for the
money but it's but it's more like like
our president and the drug czar
Botticelli right their souls are good I
think I think they're good people who
want to do a good job for the American
people and over here you have these
heads of pharmaceutical companies and
they feel like quarter-over-quarter
year-over-year their bottom line is like
air that they need to breathe so if you
have somebody who wants to do a good job
for the country versus someone who wants
to survive you're not it's not let's I
think we should be cleared the drug czar
is an awful person it's an awful office
that should not exist right we have a
drug policy yes and the entire
Louisville infrastructure is set up to
treat us as children it gives
pharmaceutical companies more power it
gives the FDA more it makes it more
difficult to come out as an addict or
having a substance abuse problem so the
government is implicated here too and
I'm the and you know what we need to do
we've grown up on many issues I think in
the country and we're starting to
undress and but it's the cursorial state
that gets in the way of all of this type
of stuff rates plummeted crime drugs
foul addiction rates fell for jail you
know whether or not office is something
I can't sit by and somebody say the drug
czar is a good person that know what you
know whether or not the office is
something that should even exist is not
something that I'm an expert on and I
don't pretend you
talk about it but I do think he's a good
soul and I do think were you running and
he's a treatment said but he might have
an opinion on that wait a minute it's
not exactly from left field we knew he's
a recovering addict like you that's
right so you know when you're in it and
these are our people you you've got a
vested interest does affect your
business you know what part of it a
having a drugs are having our policy the
way it is in this country where we
punish people instead of treat them it's
actually probably good for your business
the drug czars good for my business well
I'm just saying if if this if the
government took over would you do which
they possibly should uh-huh yeah it
might be a better system I'm not saying
they could do it better than you they
should probably hire you right but we
have a terrible system in this country
where we know why you should spell
what's that you need at a lot of
government well Nokia Knology they're
out what I'm saying is like let me tell
you this if the government takes over
both providing drugs as well as treating
drugs it's gonna suck well they're not
taking that's what free markets are for
they are very good government is
providing drugs no I'm saying if you
know if if you want the government to
get involved in no I with you on this I
wanted in criminalization of drugs and
socialized medicine punishing people and
arresting people and prosecuting jailing
people for drug crimes I spend it on
treatment socialized medicine does not
innovate in medicine the reason for
English people English National Health
System are putting a circuit our jails
is because it the jails are privatized
and that's what percentage of the
American criminal population yes and I
just had some guy come to my office jail
okay don't know wait we are the world's
biggest jailer nation absolutely and it
isn't because of private corporations 90
percent of prisoners are in you know
state-owned prisons we're locking people
up in that it isn't the profit motive
well it absolutely is the profit but the
prison guard Union yeah this is very
powerful you know and there are lobbies
are things like three strikes you're out
and they
and then prisoners are customers so
don't tell me that it's not the profit
well that I'm saying don't say it's
private absolutely
Bryan Cranston I know him what can we
expect to learn from your forthcoming
memoir ah I wrote I wrote a memoir yeah
my life in part so that I have to look
back on my life because it's over soon
right no it was just you know it's a
short stories that are autobiographical
and and I had a very challenging
childhood and in retrospect
yeah challenging didn't have a father
around there was a lot of alcoholism and
drug abuse and abandonment and you know
you you're left to your own devices at
every young age and you grow up too fast
that hope she was an actor it does in a
way it helps something to draw on when
you have to like be emotional yes oh my
dad was mean
he's drawing
I said he was a great lesbian dan Savage
in the years you've been writing a sex
advice column have people's problems
changed much thanks to abstinence
education I have a non-stop supply of
sexually miss educated idiots who are
getting and how can Donald Trump win the
election after Ellen aiding Hispanics a
key demographic and women let's be
honest didn't you see the taco balls
because Donald Trump's campaign began
with a big lie about the people who are
coming here legally or illegally
accusing them of Mexico sending their
rape is sending the murderers some of
them may be most people and that's just
a big demagogic lie that was like a shot
of adrenaline right into the worst of
our body politic it just inflamed you
know at no higher rate at a lesser rate
it's a demagogue lie because you're
likely to be raped in this country so
capital by people born in this country
it's not true but second of all even
you're not entitled still talking here
even if it were true these aren't people
who we have to have here we already have
our own rapist and MERS so you're saying
that
they are a point to a small to a racial
marginalize community vulnerable people
and accused them of being da rapist
isn't he accused Mexico of not sending
their best people and they're not
sending their best we need to build a
wall to protect us from the people who
aren't rape they were handing out first
aid kits and maps for how to get to
government to the poorest areas in
Mexico and we found them and we had them
yes they are not sending their
neuroscientist we need more we're
getting rid of their problem well yes
because you guys want your gardening
table and not competing with our
landscapers and make people who are here
and are not documented drug I hope so
because I need some right now no no it's
it's not like let me just tell you it I
get about five to ten people a year
calling me to get their kids or their
loved ones off marijuana I get out of
her money well I get ninety a day so far
than a year yeah but I get ninety a day
a prescription opiates which gives you
the right balance yes and this has been
a canard for decades but I will say and
you're probably not gonna be happy about
this you know we keep getting better as
a society and this and the science shows
now that your your brain stops
developing between the ages of 23 and 25
so if that's true I'd like to see a 25
year old age limit for pot yeah I'm not
I'm not invited back yeah
no no I'm always for the truth first any
facts first I never heard that one
I'm glad I started late I wasn't 25 but
I was 19 that's a lot I mean that's not
12 I was 12 you were 12 when you're 12
and I was 36 the first time I smoked pot
you're good
how did you start at 12 I took it from
My Father
oh my god it's like the intent should I
learned of jail Wow yeah you could teach
you to cry about it write about it in
therapy Nick will you welcome longtime
Republicans like Mary Matlin to your
party well it's not my party I don't I'm
not a member of the Libertarian Party
but she'd the Republic you're not it
just said you're so libertarian we need
to join the libertarian party all party
that's the party that expresses what I
think the government should do which is
you know a kind of basic social safety
net and defense and that's about it and
I think I think more Republicans the
ones who say that they're for limited
government they really are full of [ __ ]
for the most part okay thank you
everybody thank you audience thank you